it is very early in the morning and the
air is very cold here at kerosene Creek
a natural hot spring near Rotorua on the
North Island of New Zealand it's a
natural swimming pool and waterfall at a
warm and comfortable bathing temperature
year-round because of the geothermal
activity that's around here there is
also a questionable smell in the air but
fortunately that doesn't really come
across on camera this place is not the
local secret that it used to be tourists
flock here now which is why I'm filming
here so early I didn't really want to
turn up to a swimming pool full of
people and awkwardly point a camera on
them but there's one view that I can
show you that the tourists won't get to
see because there's a rule here that the
government warnings are very clear about
keep your head above water the
brain-eating ameba can be found in pools
and things like that so these organisms
enter the nose if you put your head
under or you snort the water in they can
then go from the nose through the
olfactory nerves to the brain and then
once in the brain they start to eat the
neurons and exercise and they cause
massive inflammation and then you get
this horrible amoeboid disease it starts
sometimes with a change in their sense
of smell sense of taste and that can
progress to headaches vomiting fever and
then ultimately to seizures and death
there are potentially a couple of drugs
that are used one of which is not
licensed for use and is actually very
difficult to get hold of so in general
there is no treatment and 97% of people
die brain-eating ameba aren't you need
to hear or even to New Zealand they're
common anywhere that there's warm
untreated water it was even a fatal case
at Disney World in Florida in 1918 back
when they had a waterpark built into a
lake and there are more odd cases too
when you've got a cold and you've got
you know you're really bummed up and
your sinuses you can flush them out it's
really important if you're going to
shove water up your nose because of the
fact that there is this amazing you know
these many nerves connecting your nose
to your brain that you use only boiled
water and so there have been cases of
people who've used neti pots just taking
tap water and they you know the
brain-eating ameba is not the only
infection people have had there
other things but there is one potential
think people can get but despite the
terrifying name the Grizzlies stories
and the 90 something percent chance of
death if you're infected infection is
really rare how much of that is down for
the government warnings though well
probably best not to have a control
group for that experiment although that
said the warning signs that were once
here aren't here anymore so what are the
odds of it happening they're very very
very rare the last case we had in New
Zealand was I think in 2000 but I guess
the point is when it does happen it's
pretty catastrophic there will be things
that we're doing in our daily lives that
are way more dangerous than theirs
you know even from a microbial point of
view we are you know covered in microbes
we have really nicely microbes kind of
living in us and Ana's on a daily basis
and most the time it's you know it's
okay maybe one and three one in four
people will have staph aureus living up
their nose pretty fine up there but if
you get that in your bloodstream you can
end up with horrible infection you're
more at risk frankly from shoving your
finger up your nose and then touching a
cat accidentally then you are from
having your brain eaten by an amoeba
thanks to dr. Wiles at the University of
Auckland for all her expertise pull down
the description for the references she
used in her research
you